let's go next to um
let me go to kenny in phoenix kenny and
phoenix you're on the air
uh good morning david how are you i'm
good how are you doing
good i'm eating breakfast right now oh
all right what are you having
uh some bacon some eggs and toast with
butter oh my goodness turkey bacon i'm
sure right
no sir unfortunately the full thing okay
very very good
oh yeah um so i wanted to ask um i
actually had a conversation with
a really good friend of mine that i've
had since uh early childhood last night
um i had a conversation with him about
politics and we've never talked about it
before
uh i consume a lot of political content
and um you know he i think this kind of
ties into the whole uh
like deprogramming thing um so i was
talking to him and he uh
he thoroughly believes all the talking
points but
he doesn't consume any media um i asked
him about it he hasn't really
watched any media he doesn't really read
any news um
he knows all this stuff through word of
mouth which is
kind of scary now when you say word of
mouth do you mean like literally do you
mean people at work telling him or do
you are you including social media in
word of mouth
um i think social media actually might
play a role
right what's up yeah i i was that's
that's i think the key thing
because at this point you know when we
talk about
like fox news for example only a few
million people are ever watching any
a particular episode of fox news this
country has 331 million people but the
point is
fox news has agenda setting power and
then you see the stories repeated on
facebook
and on twitter etc and that's where it's
being that's where it's being repeated
and that makes sense
yeah um and so so we were going back and
forth about the
election fraud thing and i kept trying
to i i don't think he really understood
um you know how all this stuff works and
i think you know i think a lot of people
don't
yeah so like what what do you think and
it was it was so hard to to you know be
polite right because
as someone who's paying attention to
this stuff it's like it's it's it's
really frustrating you know
so i guess like what i just wanted to
pick your brain and see like what do you
think maybe some strategies might be to
like
uh i guess like calmly uh you know
attack this i guess i mean with someone
that's that uninformed and who's
basically just getting
what other people they know are sharing
on facebook for example they're not even
necessarily
it's not even about getting them to look
at different news outlets because
they're not even looking at news
you have to start really softly with
where where did you where did you learn
that and
getting them to say and then say oh and
how do you know
that that's trustworthy you know they
say well my aunt aunt beatrice shared it
on facebook
okay well what what does aunt beatrice
do for work
oh well i don't know sure she works in a
factory oh all right so clearly she got
it from somewhere she this wasn't her
research where did she get it
well i guess i don't know where she got
it okay well you know you can
you can find out for yourself there are
primary sources on this stuff
you've got to start getting them open to
the idea
that they may be hearing things that
aren't true but it is
it's really tough it's very very
difficult yeah
it can be really hard when uh like one
thing i think a lot of people on the
right tend to do
is like they'll uh do all their own
research
and they'll end up at a lot of very
interesting conclusions
right but research often just means you
look at articles on breitbart you know
yeah pretty much right and then it's
like well i can come back at them with
ten articles that say hey you're not
right man
yeah well you can't believe everything
you read on the internet it's just like
oh man
this uh it yeah it can be a little
stressful i mean the problem is that
with a lot of these things
you you know there's this false notion
that it's up to sort of like opinion
like for example
does cutting taxes for the rich help the
economy
that's an empirical question and we can
look in history
at changes to tax rates and then the
associated changes in gdp employment etc
there's a lot of people who
unfortunately are in the paradigm of
well i don't know because you know the
nation says one thing and breitbart says
a different thing and then tucker says
one thing but then msnbc says something
else
you can go and look at economic
papers that are peer-reviewed from
you know groups of economists and
actually
answer that question but the problem is
a lot of people either
aren't aware or don't know or or have
the interest in actually doing that but
a lot of these things are really
they're knowable they're not really
opinion they're not really up for debate
yeah so i i guess um i guess like a big
first step is going to be trying to
i guess get uh like get these people to
understand that academics have
um what is it like uh
like they're held accountable it has
accountability yeah and i think the
first step is just getting people to
recognize
that there's limits to what they know
you if once people recognize that
their their their knowledge is limited
and there's more out there that's step
one and
unfortunately a lot of people are either
just naturally in curious or just busy
living their lives where
they take that thing they see on
facebook and that's as far as they go
and that's that's that's not a good uh
recipe
yeah that makes sense kenny great to
hear from you i really appreciate it
thank you have a good one all right
we're gonna take a quick break if you're
holding to talk to me please don't hang
up because we're going right back to the
phones momentarily
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense
each one into text or audio that you can
get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
slash pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video